my name is Peter bad welcome to finally
being a fan
how's it going everyone it wasn't that
intro or just awesome it was made by
Jerry see 40:47 but anyway welcome to my
show my name is Ian
Pat and welcome to go left you go right
we go Friday food pit-pat
on a yeah that action right the craft
anyway first off thank you all for 30
that's two digits that's me know where I
was going back 30 was a bunch of zeros
thousand subscribers we did it it's
really awesome that I without the and
burger but it's really awesome that we
managed to get a high number like that
but I want more
always
driver seriously right go my camera has
a really good tendency of falling off I
should probably tape it or something so
I wanted me to really find a picture
about me you know that I always hit my
leg when I play amnesia I don't mean us
you go first
it's good yeah it's good yes I'm just in
this guy you said it was gay tomorrow oh
oh
seriously awesome what I [ __ ] hit my
leg in the lake
someone made a picture on facebook that
I should take them together I made I
make sure it there there you go I stop I
think it's like five times
um so yeah for these fridays with
pewdiepie you guys the most highest
rated comment was teach me how to swear
it feels worse to swear in swedish i
usually I prefer swearing
but let's start with the base so I guess
the first you got to know as yeah blah
yeah if you want to add something for
yeah
yeah I'm naughty it's like [ __ ] but I'd
say it's him it's a nice what is it I'd
say it's a nicer way to say yeah and
then you want to say bottle left which
me basically his penis
so yeah bottle left mm-hm
if something bad happens I get you hit
your toe and you're like and you're like
yeah blah blah let me know in the
comments what you want for next week I
don't know I won't hold it on everyone
for last
but anyway um I have a big product for
next week so definitely don't miss next
week yeah it's um it's I can't say what
it is
super-secret our River anyway that's it
for this week's I hope you enjoyed um I
have a question for you my female
subscribers like what should I call you
I call I call everyone my bros but I
never thought that that actually doesn't
fit girls very well so my bros and my
hos not my bros and my brownie
I said bronies once and everyone was
like yeah bro but I like what I didn't
know bronies would look something but I
guess grossest I like roses but let me
know in the comments what you want
anyway brofist in 3 ok 3
don't don't think you're like one of
those whose too cool to brofist in the
camera just ROFL ok 1 why you don't
don't deny my bro for some hanging
okay row 1 - ha ha ha ha ah yeah hey I'm
just kidding okay here we go 1 2